nuestra meta es calcular la solubilidad
molar del cloruro de plomo que es un
compuesto poco soluble y nos dan la
constante del producto de solubilidad
kps que es igual a 1.6 por 10 a la menos
5 a 25 grados esta vez estamos empezando
con una solución 0.1 molar de cloruro de
potasio tenemos un vaso de precipitado
aquí y tenemos una solución punto 1
molar de cloruro de potasio eso
significa que la concentración de iones
de potasio en solución es de punto 1
molar y la concentración de añón es de
cloruro también es de punto 1 molar así
que tenemos un poco de cloruro de plomo
sólido
este representa nuestro cloruro de plomo
sólido y lo que nos pide el enunciado es
calcular cuánto de nuestro cloruro de
plomo se disolverá si lo añadimos a
nuestra solución de cloruro de potasio
una parte de nuestro cloruro de plomo se
disolverá y eventualmente alcanzará el
equilibrio continuamos escribiendo eso
aquí tenemos al cloruro
plomo sólido' y una parte de este se
disolverá y nos dará iones de plomo dos
más en solución y también vamos a
obtener uniones cloruro en solución
obtendremos cl - cuando balance hace
esto verás que necesitas un 2 en frente
de los cañones de cloruro y todo lo
demás tendrá un nulo pensamos primero en
la concentración inicial de nuestros
productos cuál es nuestra concentración
inicial de tv2 más antes de que añadamos
nuestro cloruro de plomo nada se ha
disuelto aún no tenemos una
concentración de plomo 2 más nada se ha
disuelto antes de que nuestro cloruro de
plomo se haya disuelto tenemos también
cero para nuestra concentración de
aniones cloruro del cloruro de plomo
pero si tenemos una concentración de
añón es de cloruro de nuestra solución
punto 1 molar de k cl
así que empezamos con una concentración
inicial de punto 1 molar para nuestros
aviones de cloruro ahora pensemos en el
cambio una parte de nuestro cloruro de
plomo se disolverá y vemos a esa
concentración la variable x vamos a
perder una concentración de cloruro de
plomo y por cada molde cloruro de plomo
que se disuelve obtenemos un molde iones
de plomo dos más en solución si perdemos
un valor x de cloruro de plomo obtenemos
x para el plomo dos más y por cada mol
de cloruro de plomo que se disuelve
obtenemos dos moles de aniones de
cloruro obtendremos 2x aquí para
nuestros iones de cloruro así que
nuestra unión común para este problema
es de la unión cloruro
porque tenemos dos orígenes una fuente
es nuestro cloruro de potasio y la otra
fuente es nuestro cloruro de plomo en
equilibrio la concentración de nuestros
productos será 0 + x para el plomo 2 + o
x
y 0.12 x para los aviones cloruro esto
es igual a 0.1 más 2x
después escribimos nuestra expresión de
equilibrio así que nuestra constante del
producto de solubilidad acá ps será
igual a la concentración de nuestros
productos la concentración de co2 más
elevada a la potencia del coeficiente el
coeficiente aquí es 1
por lo que este se elevará a la primera
potencia y multiplicamos eso por la
concentración de añón es cloruro en
solución cl - y elevamos eso a la
potencia de nuestro coeficiente nuestro
coeficiente es un 2
así que elevamos eso a la segunda
potencia luego continuemos sustituyendo
nuestra constante del producto de
solubilidad kps es igual a 1.6 por 10 a
la menos 5 es igual a la concentración
de iones de plomo dos más en equilibrio
y dijimos que sería x esto es x a la
primera potencia multiplicado por la
concentración de añón es cloruro en
equilibrio que es punto uno más 12 x al
cuadrado
tenemos 0.1 más 2
y todo eso al cuadrado luego tenemos que
obtener el valor de x en el lado
izquierdo tenemos 1.6 por 10 a la menos
5 es igual a x a la primera potencia y
por aquí 0.1 2x podríamos desarrollar
eso pero para hacer nuestras vidas más
simples
normalmente consideramos que x es muy
pequeña en comparación con punto 1 y si
x es muy pequeña comparándola con punto
1.1 2 x es aproximadamente lo mismo que
punto 1
continuamos escribiendo punto 1 en lugar
de punto 1 2 x y 0.1 al cuadrado es 0.01
así que del lado derecho tenemos x x
0.01 y esto es igual a 1.6 por 10 a la
menos 5 cuando calcula el valor de x
tienes que x es igual a 0.00 16 molar y
entonces ésta sería la concentración de
iones de plomo 2 más si volvemos aquí
arriba podemos ver que la concentración
de iones de plomo 2 más es x esa es
nuestra concentración y también es la
solubilidad molar del cloruro de plomo
cierto esa es la cantidad disuelta
continuamos escribiendo eso aquí nuestra
meta es calcular la solubilidad molar
que es igual a
0.00 16 molar ahora recuerda que está en
la solubilidad molar para el cloruro de
plomo en nuestra solución de cloruro de
potasio esto se disuelve en el cloruro
de potasio en el vídeo de la constante
del producto de solubilidad encontramos
la solubilidad molar cuando era solo
agua y si ves ese vídeo verás que
calculamos una solubilidad molar de
punto 0 16 molar esto fue en agua pura
no teníamos nada de cloruro de potasio
aquí y observa lo que hizo el añadir
cloruro de potasio a la solubilidad
molar hizo que disminuyera la
solubilidad un factor de 10 compara
estos valores de aquí la solubilidad del
agua pura fue de 0.0 16 y ahora la
solubilidad ha disminuido es de 0.00 16
es una décima parte de la solubilidad
original y esto se debe a la presencia
de unión común y el guión común fue
nuestro ion cloruro de acuerdo con el
principio de ley atelier un sistema que
ha sido sacado del equilibrio cambiará
su posición de equilibrio para reducir
la perturbación aplicada podemos
utilizar esa idea en esta situación si
pensamos en una reacción que está en
equilibrio incrementar la concentración
tu producto aquí se incrementa la
concentración de tussam iones cloruro
esa es nuestra perturbación nuestra
perturbación es el incremento en la
concentración de nuestro producto el
equilibrio se desplaza para disminuir la
perturbación el equilibrio se mueve
hacia la izquierda y el exceso de añón
es cloruro que tenemos se combinan con
iones de plomo dos más para formar más
de nuestro sólido por lo tanto
disminuimos la solubilidad del cloruro
de plomo debido a la presencia de
nuestro guión común observar que la kps
no cambia la cape s aún es 1.6 por 10 a
la menos 5 pero la solubilidad molar ha
sido afectada por la presencia de
nuestro guión común unión común
disminuye la solubilidad de nuestro
compuesto poco soluble y en este caso
por un factor de 10 podemos utilizar
este concepto en una separación de
mezclas en el laboratorio digamos que
tenemos algo de cloruro de plomo
sólido y nuestra meta es aislar todo el
sólido antes de que los filtramos
podemos añadir un ión común podemos
agregar una fuente de aniones cloruro y
debido al efecto del guión común que
disminuye la solubilidad del cloruro de
plomo obtendremos más de nuestro sólido
porque nuestra meta es aislar la mayor
cantidad posible de nuestro sólido ese
es un uso del efecto de lyon común en la
separación de mezclas en el laboratorio